one of the biggest mistakes a
screenwriter makes on page one ooh
mistakes on page one I think one of the
biggest mistakes is jumping into
something that's not going to teach us
anything so it doesn't matter to the
story but you think it's cool right so
understanding that those first few pages
are about the setup right so this is
this is me gathering information about
the character about the world about you
know I'm gonna start making assumptions
about what's gonna happen I'm not
looking for the inciting incident on
page one but I am looking for things
that are intentional and things that are
gonna help me understand at least who
this character is
so that's why you'll see a lot of action
films open with an action scene because
you're teaching me the skills that this
protagonist has you're teaching me that
they know how to fight they're usually
the good guy they're usually the winners
or whatever other information that you
need me to know and so now when the
inciting incident does happen and they
say you're gonna have to go off and save
the world I believe they can do it
because you've already shown me that
they can so I think it's easy on page
one to just like open with something
that like you know we call it the
opening image right and then on that
opening image we're thinking okay let's
do something big let's do something cool
it's like but if that doesn't have
anything to do with your story or if it
doesn't have anything to do with helping
to build who your character is that also
should have something to do with the
story
because you can tell me all kinds of
things about your character but if that
doesn't matter to the story then I don't
need to know you might need to know as a
writer because it's gonna inform you as
you're right
but do I need to know as an audience so
I think sometimes we get stuck in a
place where we're talking about
something that's cool or talking about
something that is exciting but it really
has nothing to do with anything and now
you've lost that executive who's only
given you ten pages in the first place
because you've just spent the first
three pages with two people at a cafe
talking about something that's very
interesting but then we never see that
person they were just talking to ever
again and whatever it is they were
talking about has nothing to do with
what our protagonist is about to go and
you know journey go on on this journey
hey Christy why do you think people do
that why like we wouldn't it
but it like you said it doesn't even it
doesn't get back I think it just goes
back to them not understanding
screenplay structure I think we just
watch movies and if you're only watching
for entertainment which is what most
people do that's why people want to go
to the movies with me or watch TV with
me because I'm not watching right but
you know most people who are watching
for entertainment are just taking in the
cool stuff you know and they go oh my
god wasn't it so cool when this open
like that it's like yes but what does
that have to do with your screenplay do
you know like oh well you remember in
this movie when this happened so at this
point in 2020 we all grew up watching
movies right so that means there are
movie things that we get attached to
right so we're not necessarily thinking
about story we think about movie moments
you know like that's just a part of like
can you imagine the people who are
growing up now like movie moments are
gonna be their thing so a lot of the
times people are writing screenplays
because they're writing what they what
they've seen already because they think
that those are the movie moments that
make the film instead of realizing that
movie moment mattered because of who
those characters were and what they were
trying to get done it means absolutely
nothing in your screenplay it means
budget in your experience like you know
we recently had a screenwriting teacher
tell us that 99% of screenplays are
rejected by the industry after the first
scene so yeah again if those first 10 or
15 pages I wouldn't necessarily say it's
the first scene it depends on who you're
sending it to because most places will
say at least to give it the 10 pages so
that we can say that we did our due
diligence right now you could have a
scene that lasts 10 pages you know you
could have only two or three scenes
within those same pages so that's yeah
totally it happens if you if you can't
capture me if I don't care about your
character within these first 10 or 15
pages if I don't again we haven't
reached that inciting incident so I
don't even know what this thing is about
anymore so now I'm just grasping for
straws I'm reading it you know there has
to be something that connects me so that
I can want to read the rest because
people these days we'll send you a
screenplay that's 200 pages long
where's time for that if you can't
connect me in those first 10 pages I am
not about to spend my next two hours
reading 200 pages it's like for what
when there's a whole stack of screen
plays here that might capture me within
the first five or ten pages you know why
do I need to why do I need to spend my
time reading the 200 it's the same thing
when you're thinking about television so
a lot of the times people will you know
have a pilot and now they're thinking of
you know the next couple of episodes and
they're like oh my god I'm really gonna
get you at Episode five I've got to wait
five episodes before I'm invested no
one's gonna do that if you can't catch
me at the pilot I don't mean as an
audience I mean like as the executives
that's the people you're pitching to the
pilot is what sells the series if you're
telling me that you're gonna go into
this pitch meeting you're gonna say to
them wait till we get to Episode five
then that sounds like episode five
through the pilot you know like you got
to get me in here and and because it's
2020 I could be doing this I'm watching
you know I can be doing all kinds of
things I can have on what are these
things people put the like there's all
kind of technology and like I could be
looking in a whole nother dimension
right now instead of you know watching
your television show or your feature so
you know if it's gonna take five
episodes before I get there and I'm not
saying it doesn't happen because I will
watch things and go it didn't catch me
until episode three right but when
you're in the room and you're trying to
sell it that pilot is what's gonna sell
it not you saying to them because like
if they're if you just pitched your
pilot and the people are just kind of
like you're like wait wait wait I didn't
get to tell them about episode five
that's why they didn't buy it
no no they didn't buy it because the
pilot wasn't interesting or they weren't
invested in what was going on so it's
the same thing is true and once they
have the script in their hands because
you can also come in and pitch one thing
and then you get the script you're bored
to tears or you're like this is not what
you pitched you know you said it was one
thing and I'm looking at the page and
it's really this other thing sometimes
that might be a good thing sometimes may
be a bad thing but simply just because
executives are doing a million things
some of them are not just development
executives but they're also current
programming current programming
executives which means they're running
shows that are on set right now that are
in production right now that are in
writers rooms right now and they're
taking pitch meetings and reading
scripts etc so they're reading scripts
from the shows that are already being
done they're reading scripts from people
who are coming to pitch they don't have
time to read all 200 page
of your screenplay there and if they do
they're gonna scan it so they're still
not gonna even catch on catch on to like
all of the nuances and all of the
everything unless they are that invested
because you're you're you know grabbing
them that way so that's why those first
few pages have to catch them and it
doesn't mean I put an explosion so it
caught them you know because it's like
explosion for what hey you know what I
mean so it still has to make sense to
your story when you were teaching you
said at Florida State and you had the
students watch movies and then right
this was it almost like they were
writing coverage on it
oh no so we would be specifically
talking about like analyzing how
costuming and makeup may inform what you
see how lighting may inform was so we
were talking about cinematography we
were talking about directing we talked
about all of the elements of the film
industry that may be informing what
you're seeing on screen but not the
actual screenplay not the screenplay
literally just what you're seeing mm-hmm
so visual yes because people will always
say oh the writer did a great job it's
like well you don't really know at that
moment was something a that the writer
put in there or if you were feeling that
really because of what the light was
doing what the music was doing maybe you
know what the director may have asked
for what the actors are giving you may
have nothing to do with the writing it's
like literally a separate thing so yeah
we didn't study the screenplays at all
in this particular class it was just
watching the films and analyzing all of
the different elements from production
that may be informing the film what film
that you used as one of the examples had
the most different responses to it hmm
okay so I do not remember at all I know
we used to watch Annie Hall okay and we
watched do the right thing okay but
again going back to this whole writing
thing if Y if I sat down with the
students and have them explain to me
what they were saying they could do it
putting it in the written form was an
entirely different thing so just you
know again going back to everybody might
have an idea but it doesn't make them a
writer like being able to take what you
have here and put it on the page
is a skill and I think we understand
that when we're school-aged because
we're doing it all the time then we
become adults when you say I'm a writer
and it's like yeah it's hard it's hard
to get stuff from here to there so a lot
of their grade was really based on how
well they could give me the information
in the written form which is why I was
would focus on thesis statements or even
bibliographies I had a student come to
me and say she had never heard of a
bibliography and we this is an
undergraduate course okay I told her
this cannot be telling the truth
I would rather she just said I forgot to
put it in and then I would have let her
go home put it in and come back and get
a grade but because she said to me no
one's ever told me I had to cite
something before I just could not
believe it I was like that's just math
that cannot be true so I gave her a zero
on the because I told them ahead of time
if you don't cite your sources you're
going to get a zero if I hadn't told
them that and of course I would have
done it but also I explained to them
getting a zero gives you an opportunity
to redo it if I give you the actual
grade you might get a fifty or a forty
nine or something because you have did
the assignment that's you're not gonna
be able to change the zero you can
change that's fair you know redo it and
now you get a you know a new grade on it
so they would get the zero and be hurt
and hurt but they didn't realize the
zero is actually helping you because if
I actually just graded for what it is
you'd that's not the grade that you want
yeah I wish more places gave zeros that
we could redo
[Laughter]
you